es ist absolut rätselhaft woher wissen
elefanten dass ein tsunami kommt eines
ist sicher irgendwas wissen spüren tiere
was wir überhaupt nicht mitbekommen dass
sich vögel am magnetfeld der erde
orientieren das ist inzwischen
wissenschaftlich bewiesen für den
sogenannten sechs sinn wird jeder
dagegen gibt es noch keine eindeutigen
belege doch es gibt viele hinweise
darauf dass es sich vor
naturkatastrophen in sicherheit bringen
wie tiere in die zukunft sehen was der
sechste sinn der tiere wahrscheinlich
ist und ob wir das verhalten der tiere
eines tages als frühwarnsystem nutzen
können jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
auch das war übrigens einen
themenvorschlag von den klicks
whatsapp danke dafür der link zu
whatsapp kommt am ende des videos und
ist natürlich in der video beschreibung
kurz vor der jahrhundertkatastrophe ende
des jahres 2004 als ein gewaltiger
tsunami im indischen ozean und 230.000
menschen töten wird verhalten sich die
tiere der gegend äußerst unruhig
elefanten beispielsweise sie bewegen
sich nervös breiten ihre ohren aus und
schließlich drehen sie sich um und
rennen einen berg hinauf auch die vögel
steigen verschreckt in den himmel und
fliegen landeinwärts irgendwie müssen
sie wohl die drohende gefahr gewittert
haben oder war es etwa reiner zufall
doch es gibt immer wieder
medienberichten nach denen bei großen
naturkatastrophen wie eben diesen
tsunami im indischen ozean viele tiere
verschont bleiben
wohingegen ja hunderttausende menschen
in diesem fall sterben und ganze
landschaften zerstört werden könnten
also viele menschenleben vor solchen
katastrophen gerettet werden wenn wir
das verhalten der tiere beachten und es
als eine art frühwarnsystem nutzen
könnten
sicher ist jedenfalls tiere setzen
mehrere sinne gleichzeitig ein und
nehmen kleine veränderungen so sehr viel
früher war als menschen es gibt eine
studie der university of virginia als im
jahr 2009
die verschiedene erklärung für dieses
frühwarnsystem der tiere hat demnach
konnten
elefanten schon sehr viel früher hören
dass sich das wasser im indischen ozean
zurück ziehe zudem sind elefanten auch
in der lage wellenbewegungen im
untergrund zu spüren
eben genau diese die auch durch erdbeben
verursacht werden eventuell hat den auch
ihr riechorgan verraten dass das wasser
vom land zurück weicht vielleicht hat ja
auch schon einmal ähnliche geschichten
über außergewöhnliches tierverhalten vor
anderen großen naturkatastrophen gehören
china wurde nach einem erdbeben im jahr
2008 beispielsweise von tausenden von
kröten berichtet die über die straßen
hüpften später starben dann mehr als
50.000 menschen
dagegen steht die ahnungslosigkeit von
seismologen die es wenige sekunden vor
dem erdbeben wissen dass es so weit ist
bislang kann man einfach nicht
voraussagen wann und wo sich die
spannungen an den erdplatten entladen
werden zwar gibt es beispielsweise in
mexiko-stadt effiziente warnsysteme um
die menschen zu alarmieren doch das ist
fast ein einzelfall weltweit die
herausforderung liegt einfach darin dass
hochsensible sensoren gut überlegt
platziert werden müssen und elefanten
kröten und vögel stehen nicht alleine im
fokus von forschungsteams weltweit auch
bei anderen tierarten wie beispielsweise
ziegen und roten waldameisen konnten
bereits hinweise auf den sechsten sinn
der tiere beobachtet werden der deutsche
biologe martin wikelski vom max planck
institut für ornithologie hat erforscht
dass ziegen vor einem ausbruch des
vulkans ätna außergewöhnlich aktiv
wurden und dass mehrere stunden bevor
der vulkan tatsächlich aussprach damit
sind die ziegen den menschlichen
prognosen weit voraus denn ja es gibt
einige prozesse die einen vulkanausbruch
ankündigen doch der konkrete zeitpunkt
vögel aus braucht und auch seine stärke
das ist viel zu komplex um es im vorfeld
physikalisch zu berechnen jedenfalls für
uns menschen ist es unmöglich ihn
vorherzusagen und es sind nicht nur
ausschließlich säugetiere die ein solch
besonderes gespür haben auch rote
waldameise neben reagieren
offensichtlich auf ein anstehendes
erdbeben das haben deutsche
forschungsteams aus duisburg und
dortmund entdeckt zunächst sind sie wohl
durch ihre speziellen sinnesorgane in
der lage aufsteigende gase und womöglich
auch elektrische spannungen wahrzunehmen
die ameisen bauen ihre hügel also genau
dort wo sich groß und bruchstücke der
erde gegeneinander schieben
die vermutung der wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler dies versorgt sie
mit einer wärmeren und feuchteren
umgebung das deutsche forschungsteam hat
über drei jahre hinweg beobachten können
dass die ameisen sehr empfindlich auf
aktivitäten unter der erde reagierten
diese warfen ihren gewohnten und sehr
durchgeplanten tagesablauf durcheinander
doch am ende ihrer studie fordert das
forschungsteam zunächst noch weitere
untersuchungen um zufalls beobachtungen
mit aller sicherheit ausschließen zu
können
teams aus verhaltensbiologen weltweit
vermuten dass vor allem das
schwarmverhalten der tiere sie so
intelligent macht das ist interessant
das heißt also nicht die tatsache dass
ein einziger elefant spürt dass sich
etwas mit dem wasser ändert ist demnach
entscheidend stattdessen seien die
gemeinsame verarbeitung dieser reize und
die interaktion der tiere der schlüssel
vergleichbar mit dem beispiel eines
einzelnen fisches der im großen see als
individuum verloren ist als schwarm
dagegen wissen die tiere dagegen genau
wo sie futter oder einen sicheren platz
finden also eine kollektive intelligenz
quasi eine art algorithmus im verhalten
der tiere der ihnen das überleben
sichert wie genau aber stehen die
interaktion der tiere und eher verhalten
in der gruppe im zusammenhang mit dem
sechsten sinn genau dieser frage will
das so genannte ikarus projekt weiter
erforschen im kurs steht für
international cooperation for research
on you sing space der plan die schwärmer
der tiere beobachten egal wo sie sich
gerade befinden und das vom schreibtisch
aus dafür werden kleine solarbetriebene
gps sender mit einer antenne auf der
internationalen raumstation iss
verbunden also die sender sind auf den
tieren und senden zur raumstation wann
bewegen sich die tiere wohin das
bewegungsprofil von zahlreichen
elefanten vögeln und ameisen könnte am
ende endlich aufschluss über ihren sechs
hingeben und sobald dieses phänomen
genauer erforscht ist könnte man es
möglicherweise auch schon als ein
zuverlässiges prüfern system für uns
menschen nutzen wenn er als erstes neues
zum thema zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr deutlich
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion von klicks zum mitmachen und
themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos
stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken hier also da geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken top sieben
tiere auf drogen ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran